so what impact will the TPP if approved
have on the world food system what your
part we don't know the TPP has been
negotiated in secret and that's one of
the great mysteries is that we will have
something that potentially can eradicate
everything from traditional family farms
in Japan to protections on food safety
in other parts of the world we have no
idea what the TPP will entail and I
think that's that's one of the great
worries I mean when I was in Japan a
couple of years ago when there was a
large protest by Japanese farmers who
were very very concerned about the
removal of subsidies that allow them to
be able to supply the kind of rice the
Japanese consumers know and trust and be
part of a food culture that
unfortunately but will is the sort of
thing that might be designated an
impediment to trade and if culture
becomes an impediment to trade then
trade will win under the TPP as far as
we know right now but that's the mystery
we are going to be subject to a treaty
in which corporations will be able to
litigate against governments and in
which culture will be the great great
loser and corporations will be the
winner as far as we know and the problem
the TPP is it's one great mystery that's
going to drop drop on us from a great
height and about which we will have very
little say and I think that reason
enough if you're concerned about what it
is that goes into your mouth and you
want to know what's going into your
mouth then you want to know what's going
into the treaties pretty much right now
the TPP is like one strange lump lump of
mystery meat